(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Perhaps the
most resilient building
in the world can be found
in the Yangtze River in China,
where it has stood for the past 700 years.
(gentle music)
Guanyin Pavilion, also known
as the Goddess of Mercy Pavilion,
is a temple located in Ezhou City
in China's Hubei province.
Its origins date back to the Yuan Dynasty,
and is the only temple built
on the nearly 4,000-mile
long Yangtze River.
The temple sits on a large
reef rock in the river.
During the rainy season,
the temple's foundation
is submerged in water,
and the building looks
as if it's floating.
Today, the pavilion
isn't open to the public.
However, that doesn't
stop adventure swimmers
from exploring the structure.
While floods and heavy rainstorms
have washed away trees and
more modern structures,
Guanyin Pavilion still stands strong.
It's a testament to the
architectural engineering
of its ancestors.
(gentle music)
(soft mellow music)